on en vient au dernier volet du rapport
du giec publié le 4 avril dernier un
rapport qui met en avant la nécessité de
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et de garantir les financements
vers dans les pays pauvres les
précisions de notre correspondant à
niamey harold girard
l'aide suffisante attendu par les pays
en développement n'arrive pas c'est ce
que le giec précise dans le dernier
volet de son rapport ce groupe d'experts
dédiés au climat qui travaillent sur le
réchauffement climatique
conséquence en afrique les
investissements écologiques stagne alors
que partout sur le continent les
possibilités pourrait être énorme à
l'image d'ici au niger où forcément on
pense au développement de l'énergie
solaire encore trop peu avancé par
rapport aux possibilités du pays les
structures capables d'accompagner ces
projets verts comme le fonds de
solidarité africain déplore la non tenue
de la promesse des pays du nord vers
ceux du sud une promesse on le rappelle
qui engage 100 milliards de dollars par
an d'investissements dans des projets
verts ressources financières dont nous
disposons ne sont pas adaptés au
financement des projets énergétiques
surtout dans le domaine du renouvelable
et c'est pour cette raison les
engagements qui ont été pris au niveau
des différents corps sous le bain
international ses engagements devraient
être tenus de façon à ce que les pays
pollueurs puisse financer les projets
énergétiques qui sont de nature à
atténuer les effets
du réchauffement climatique
aujourd'hui en dehors des engagements
qu'il n'y a pas eu d'action le niger
subi de plein fouet les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique en 2021 le pays
a connu une de ces sécheresses les plus
intenses une sécheresse qui a mené à la
baisse des rendements agricoles de près
de 40% en 2022 le niger pourrait
connaître sa pire crise alimentaire
depuis 10 ans ou plus